Irlanda es el país con la mayor densidad de músicos famosos per cápita de todo el mundo, tal cual como lo oís
hablamos de un país con menos de cinco millones de habitantes
para que os hagáis una idea la capital del perú lima tiene casi el doble de población, pues bien en este país tan despoblado
es donde han nacido estrellas de la talla de sinéad o'connor, Cranberries, Enya, The Chieftains y por supuesto Bono el de U2
estrella del rock a lo mejor de las más influyentes y de las mas acojonantes
pero hay otra cosa por la que irlanda también es famosa
seguro que muchos de los que estáis viendo este vídeo sobre todo desde españa estaréis pensando en emigrar este país y razones no faltan
hablamos del segundo país más rico de la eurozona
los irlandeses tienen más dinero que sus vecinos del reino unido o de suiza y todo esto debería
sorprendernos si tenemos en cuenta que hace sólo 30 años
irlanda era un país tan pobre como lo puede ser grecia
Tal cual como lo ois, por aquel entonces
uno de cada cinco estudiantes irlandeses
emigraba a otros países como estados unidos o australia
es más a día de hoy en estos lugares hay más población con sangre irlandesa
que en la propia irlanda y sin embargo hoy en día es una de las mecas
tecnológicas del mundo muchos pensaréis que la razón que explica este crecimiento
tan espectacular se debe únicamente a los impuestos bajos, es cierto que irlanda ofrece condiciones fiscales
muy favorables para que se establezcan las grandes multinacionales
Pero pensándolo bien porque otros países como las islas seychelles o la república de liberia también
ofrecen condiciones fiscales muy favorables y no son ni la mitad de ricos que irlanda
así que la pregunta es ,qué ha hecho este país para lograr semejante crecimiento
económico cómo es posible que incluso tras la crisis financiera, irlanda
siga siendo un país a la altura de suiza hoy vamos a responder a esas preguntas pero antes vamos a hacer un poco de historia
Los más pobres de los ricos irlanda nació en el año
1922 tal cual como lo ois, hasta entonces toda la isla
pertenecía a la corona británica y las relaciones con la metrópoli no eran especialmente
buenas para los ingleses
irlanda era una tierra de
católicos paletos que odiaban el trabajo y que se dedicaban a tener hijos como si no
existiera el mañana y por eso tras declarar su independencia
una de las primeras cosas que hace irlanda es cortar todas sus relaciones con londres y ya de paso con el resto del mundo
Para que os hagáis una idea
irlanda es el único país angloparlante
que se declaró neutral durante la segunda guerra mundial pero no sólo eso durante años los sucesivos gobiernos
irlandeses cerraron el país a cal y canto y lo protegieron del comercio internacional e incluso
llegaron a prohibir que los extranjeros
pudieran comprar o invertir en empresas locales y cuál fue el resultado de estas políticas
pues una crisis económica bestial por suerte como los irlandeses
hablan inglés en lugar de morirse de hambre
hacía las maletas y se marchaban a estados unidos y ojo que no hablamos de unos pocos aventureros sin apenas unas pocas décadas
la población de irlanda se redujo a la mitad
Por supuesto la industria nacional nunca llegó a tener según que se esperaban pensarlo bien
en un país tan pequeño es imposible encontrar las herramientas y las materias primas necesarias
para poder construir máquinas y fábricas, así que se tienen que importar
pero si el gobierno se dedica a poner aranceles y barreras para las cosas que compras en el exterior lo vas a tener
bastante complicado si quieres montar tu propia empresa y por eso en
1957 bajo el gobierno
de Seán Tomás Ó Ceallaigh
irlanda da un giro de 180 grados a su política comercial
así es cómo pasan de no
comprarle nada al resto del mundo a abrir de par en par las puertas del país al mercado internacional
Años después
entrarían en la comunidad europea que es lo que ahora conocemos como la unión europea pero, esperar un momento
mis queridos amigos liberales que sé que muchos estáis viendo este vídio
contened vuestro entusiasmo por un momento porque esta apertura al libre mercado
pensadlo bien, durante décadas irlanda había cerrado comercios y había nacionalizado buena parte de sus empresas
cuando una empresa sabe que no tiene que competir por conseguir clientes dejan de invertir dinero en ipurúa
1980 los habitantes de la ciudad de cork en el sur de la isla estuviesen tan acostumbrados a los apagones electricos
lógicamente tenía una red de cableado que nos había reparado ni renovado desde hacia decadas
haci ocurria prácticamente con cualquier otro sector económico cuando de repente la economía irlandesa
permite comprar bienes en el extranjero
y que ocurre con las empresas locales? os preguntaréis pues que desaparecen y con ellas miles de personas pierden su trabajo
Para que os hagáis una idea
en 1987 irlanda tenía un
17 por ciento de desempleo así que nuevamente
los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que la inmigración no es un problema para un país
lo contrario, la emigración en el caso de irlanda quien se marchaba del país? pues justo aquellos que estaban mejor preparados
mejor cualificados y que tenían normalmente títulos universitarios o de educación
superior, a este fenómeno se le conoce como fuga de cerebros
Pero esperad un momento porque todavía hay más para atraer a esas multinacionales estadounidenses
el gobierno de irlanda había bajado los impuestos y por supuesto que esta estrategia les funcionó
empresas como microsoft o intel o apple eligieron irlanda como su sede fiscal para todo el mercado europeo
el problema que sólo montaban una oficina comercial
con un contable es decir que su contribución a la riqueza del país era francamente pobre por si esto fuera poco
el mismo gobierno que le ponía una alfombra roja las empresas subían los impuestos a los ciudadanos
que llegaban a pagar hasta un 60 por ciento de su renta como os podéis imaginar
con algo tenía que financiar un estado que quería parecerse a dinamarca pero sin tener el dinero
y por si esto fuera poco la legislación irlandesa
tampoco ponía las cosas muy fáciles para los locales que querían montar empresas y contratar a gente así que
fijaros en la estampa destrucción de empleo destrucción de empresas locales un gasto público
imposible de pagar y cientos de miles de irlandeses
1988 y en estos momentos The Economist saca este artículo hablando de la tierra que vio nacer a bono
Los más pobres de los ricos la poblana se había portado como si fuera rica y ahora debe pagar el precio
vale bien ya hemos visto todo lo malo y ahora la pregunta es cómo consiguieron salir de este bache
El rugido del tigre celta
año 1987 Charles Haughey gana las elecciones al gobierno irlandés y se encuentra con un país sumido en la más absoluta miseria
y se da cuenta de algo muy importante, no puedes abrir un país a la economía internacional sin antes
mejorar tu sistema productivo doméstico
Por supuesto que empresas como oracle o hp estaban
estaban dispuestas a montar una fábrica ,un centro de investigación que diera trabajo a miles de personas? la respuesta es no
Porque os preguntaréis lo primero es que tenían que lidiar con la legislación laboral
irlandesa que era todo un viacrucis legal pero no sólo eso recordáis decía que los impuestos sobre la renta
llegaban hasta el 60 por ciento eso significa que por muy altos que fueran los sueldos lo que le llegaba al trabajador a su bolsillo
era una ínfima parte de lo que le pagaban en otras palabras que esas
irlandeses que tenían buena formación buena cualificación y que podían trabajar en las empresas de alta tecnología
Por cierto que esto tan bonito que está sonando es The Forgotten Boys un grupo de rock de
irlanda que nos ha mandado su música si os gusta encontraréis más información sobre ellos en los enlaces de la descripción
Así que la primera medida dejar ni consistió en llegar a un acuerdo con la patronal y los sindicatos
para que los sueldos crecieran al ritmo que crecía la economía del país por el otro lado
terminaban ganando más dinero con el mismo salario y sabéis que? en pocos años estas medidas empezaron a dar resultados
La planta de Hewlett Packard Leixlip dará dos mil trabajos para el año 2000
en poco tiempo todas estas empresas que habían montado su sede fiscal en territorio irlandés empezaron a abrir también
fábricas y centros de investigación en los que tenían que contratar a montones de
trabajadores así que el desempleo se recortaba los sueldos subían y además el estado recaudará más dinero pero no sólo eso
toda esta reducción de trabas burocráticas
unida al pacto social
Quién de vosotros no ha volado alguna vez en ryanair y quien de vosotros no se ha comprado alguna vez
una camiseta en el primark quien no se ha bebido alguna vez una cerveza guinness pues todas estas empresas
fueron creadas o se expandieron
internacionalmente en estos años y eso explica que en los años 90 la economía irlandesa
creciera casi al mismo ritmo que la de china
de repente era normal que llegaras a una peluquería de dublín y de ofrecieran una copita de
champán o que mucha gente se fuera a pasar el fin de semana a nueva york para hacer compras eran los años del llamado
hace una decada los sueldos irlandeses no llegaban a dos terceras partes de los britanicos, el año pasado en algunos sectores
lo superaron pero espera de un momento porque no todo es tan bonito
en estos años de optimismo exacerbado los bancos se dedicaron a dar hipotecas a todo hijo de vecino
sin siquiera mirar si eran solventes y por supuesto también daban préstamos para financiar
toda clase de derroches de lo más
rocambolesco para que os hagáis una idea en esta época llegó a surgir una empresa que alquilaba helicópteros para que los niños y las niñas
hicieran su primera comunión por los aires para que os hagáis una idea en estos años llegó a surgir una empresa que
alquilaba helicópteros para que los niños y las niñas
hicieran su primera comunión desde los aires
y todo esto llevo a una crisis financiera de la que hablaremos en otro vidio si no os lo quereis perder
suscribios al canal para estar al tanto de todas nuestras actualizaciones
mientras tanto despues de conocer algo mas de la politica irlandesa, deberiais echar un vistazo a la de escocia
en este vídeo os explico por qué escocia volvera a intentar de independizarse del reino unido ,haced click aquí para verlo
y ahora la pregunta es qué creéis que el modelo irlandés podría servir para otros países como españa o grecia
os parece que otros países de latinoamérica
podrian beneficiarse de atraer y mantener a empesas multinacionales extranjeras
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios si os ha gustado este vídeo darle a laik y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto